[Musik]
die elbphilharmonie architekten jacques
herzog und pierre de meuron
das guggenheim museum in new york frank
lloyd wright das guggenheim museum in
bilbao von frank gehry fällt ihnen etwas
auf alle gebäude monumental alle von
männern entworfen eth zürich
departements für architektur 46
professuren von denen nur zehn mit
frauen besetzt sind
bei dem studenten jedoch sieht es anders
aus
seit 2005 liegt der frauenanteil
konstant bei mindestens 43 prozent
[Musik]
und hurts team in der arbeitswelt sind
später nur noch ein viertel aller
architekten frauen tragisch wurde ja
unterwegs blieb dagegen scheint mir kein
ganz befriedigende antworten
barbara wyss kümmern und michael motto
haben für sich eine antwort gefunden
beide studierten an der eth beide haben
familie sie machten sich selbstständig
in einer branche die kaum rücksicht
nimmt auf die bedürfnisse einer familie
in der teilzeitarbeit nur schwer möglich
ist
in der männer dominieren die beiden
sehen das gelassen solange liter komisch
wie ist das eigentlich überhaupt heißt
problem chemie als einrichter lässigste
ort mexiko die sache von papier und doch
es ist eine welt in der es schnell gehen
muss
kostendruck zeitdruck konkurrenz und
über alldem das klischee dass männer
damit besser umgehen können dass man als
frau nur noch besser sein müsse dann
werde sich schon alles richten lernt
immer grant leichteste punkten waren die
hochburg ist ein kunst schon einen job
zu finden
es hat einfach viel frau kathi coburg
sind und ich hab die war nämlich das was
prägt sich einem schon eine erfahrung
die auch beatrice abbey gemacht hat auch
sie dachte beruflicher qualität setzte
sich durch und beruf und kinder das sei
vereinbar
doch sie erlebte lohn diskriminierung
und ungleichbehandlung honig im
wintermonat von vom chef
eine große schlichte stadtmeisterschafts
leichtigkeit degradiert eine konsequenz
aus dieser erfahrung sie begründete das
netzwerk frau und es
innerhalb des berufsverbands der
ingenieure und architekten
hier will sie frauen dazu bewegen sich
über missstände der arbeitswelt
auszutauschen
meine kollegin und da sich das dass ich
das jetzt neu zusammensetzen und die
wichtige erkenntnis aus dem austausch
mit meiner kolleginnen stieg sie dass
mir das aber nicht als individuelles
versagen ist sondern dass es ist sich
dem problem ist frauen müssten gezielt
mehr netzwerken erfahrungen austauschen
meint beatrice aepli sich sichtbar
machen wie die landesgruppe sichtlich
und landschaften geht es nach mobilität
und mehrfach irgendwo das ablagesystem
ihre ansprüche selbstbewusst
hervorbringen mit bittstellerin sondern
mit des angebots macher von kompetenz
kooperationsfähigkeit womit zusammen mit
einander die berufliche spektrum mit den
angestaubten aber alles kümmern und
michelle modus versuchen das zu
realisieren
und beides beruf und familie zu
vereinbaren
ein miteinander jenseits männlich
dominierter arbeitsstrukturen und
tradierten geschlechterrollen
es braucht die familie
und überhaupt nicht immer die gleiche
person beschränkt also zuständig
eine quote für frauen auf dem freien
markt ist für architektinnen schwer
realisierbar
vielleicht ist es bei öffentlichen
aufträgen möglich doch wie sieht es mit
der quote für institutionen aus der
hochschule vor 50 jahren über diese
frage an der eth am department für
architektur
wenn man seit herbst mit
missbrauchsvorwürfen konfrontiert ist
nimmt man das gleichstellungs thema
ernst in einem interview mit der nzz
meint vorsteher philip ursprung
das primäre ziel ist eine balance der
geschlechter den rollenvorbilder für
männliche und weibliche studierende
haben eine zentrale funktion zu einer
quote für frauen will er sich aber nicht
äußern
auf nachfrage hieß es am telefon für
hahn ursprung sei es ein thema unter
vielen
[Musik]